your kids have had a different life than
you had growing up right do sometimes
they don't have the same they don't it's
just and there's nothing you can do
about it because because so much is
given to it it's crazy and that crazy
brother they don't they don't have they
don't have near by the same and you
can't recreate that you can't name ten
percent of the kids under 15 while
saving money yeah you came in because
it's different it's different you know
you you can't name kids and you can't
name too many you know it people
everything is right here and there yeah
they're not that good for nothing they
want to know if a girl like I'm it's
right there they want to find out about
a job they want to ask something is
right there you know it is different you
know and I feel like that disabled kids
disabled a lot of athletes in the world
because a lot of kids don't want to go
out and play they just want to see right
here well yeah oh yeah well they got me
a 49 if you was raised in the 80s and
90s you had to be here to be outside
yeah your fun had to come from outside
yeah you had to make it you had to make
it yeah now we got all right here now
now everything is all right here they
look like creatures almost when they get
locked in right right you didn't have to
go really study the spelling test and
all you just pull it up yeah you know do
you is it an interesting no how you
can't recreate that for them you can't
it's like it's weird once you get a
generation of wealth is there's
something that it does negatively
negatively to the next generation yes
not crazy
yes that's crazy I was just watching
that on a show on on American greed what
happened to with some [ __ ] just like
that because we give it to them but we
didn't that you see that's what happened
with my with my couple my kids I gave it
to him so two three thousand is not a
lot of money to right blow through this
[ __ ] that's crazy you know so I'm
raising my mind my other generation of
kids my nine ten eleven year old every
day I go to work every day I'm in
Atlanta I go to work they gotta get up
and go to work with
we shoot videos they gotta have the
props they gotta be working right and
this is every day if they got they gotta
check in at my door at 7:30 yeah this
said I'm gonna make them work for
everything right I paid them $150 a day
when they go work with me nice I told me
you stay with your daddy to someone at 7
says $17,000 that piece for you and this
is instilled in their head now that's
how you make money you work that's how
you make money you work right so when
they get 16 they not go it gonna be like
a senior ask me for money yeah they're
gonna be so so I'm stacking and once you
get to see those bands take my boys fell
in love with it my boss they say dad I
made $1,200 in eight days out of a trip
you know it's exciting it's exciting but
if we just and just give it to him they
would never know the word crazy though
innit crazy because you would think
though you would think they would have
the same - sure it doesn't carry it
doesn't it's really interesting man yeah
cuz my brother and I when we were
growing up we didn't have anything but
now my brothers were works really hard
in Baton Rouge he has a tree-cutting
company and uh and now he has kids they
have a different life you know and it's
part of it so he's like you would have
had that of you out ere Ridge cares no I
wouldn't be the same person I would
never been a comedian because I had to
be a comedian to defend myself the only
thing I had when I was young was my
words you know like I couldn't know if
we didn't have the extra stuff but words
were mine you couldn't words I had they
came from me right like anybody could
have something else you could have the
new Reebok pumps whatever you could have
all the [ __ ] but my words were mine you
know and so when it came to humor or
words and I said oh this is my weapon
because nobody can control if I have
this or not I wake up with my words
every day right so that's why I think I
got into doing stand-up because oh this
I can do this know everybody has this
but if I master it then it's like I
don't know it's me showing them I'm
gonna show them you know even if I
didn't have some of the same things look
I'm gonna make the most of what I do
you know my words right right I just
wish it I just I just wish it would just
carry on I know man it's crazy and it's
almost sad to see it not carry on cuz
you're watching you yeah but but they
right well it's yeah yeah so it's like
are you the bad influence weird it's
weird like it's weird man like do they
see how hard I'm working for this [ __ ]
like you know yeah I don't know it's
funny this it's interesting to see if
they recognize good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one